la violence à l'école avec je vous le
disais cette nouvelle agression dans un
lycée
l'enseignante n'est pas blessée mais
elle est très choquée ce qui retient
l'attention c'est que l'attaqué était
totalement gratuite apparemment elle
n'avait pas d'autre motif que d'être
filmée par un autre élève avec son
téléphone portable et diffusée montré
comme un trophée sur place à porcheville
près de versailles aurélia guillemin
frédéric de la rue
devant les grilles du lycée lavoisier
les images passent de téléphone en
téléphone elle circule même sur internet
lundi en pleine classe un élève de cet
établissement s'est jeté sur sa
professeure pendant qu'un autre filmait
la scène avec son portable la séquence
dure quinze secondes elle a été diffusée
à la plupart des lycéens voit tout la
personne il a décrit et c'est vraiment
pas acceptable qu est-ce qui a envoyé à
qui tu as envoyé la vidéo tafer le pubis
l'agresseur un élève de 2e année de bep
âgé de 18 ans ces professeurs avaient
noté chez lui des difficultés scolaires
mais pas d'agressivité particulière il
n'ya il n'y a eu aucune explication
donnée par l'élève
devant mes demandes et le professeur
elle ne comprenait pas ce qui s'était
passé puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu
d'altercation particulière avec cette
élève depuis le début depuis le début de
l'année l'agression at-elle été commises
dans le seul but d'être filmé les
enquêteurs se pose la question ils sont
toujours à la recherche de l'auteur des
images susceptibles d'être poursuivis
pour complicité de violence on a
quelqu'un qui a peut-être été complice
qui n'est pas intervenue qui n'a pas
porté secours et qui a voulu au
contraire et bien ensuite paradé en
publiant des des images de ces faits
totalement inadmissible le téléphone
portable pour filmer des agressions ou
des dégradations
le phénomène déjà bien visible pendant
les manifestations anti cpe semble
prendre de l'ampleur il inquiète la
police ça va faire un petit peu comme le
système d des véhicules brûlés ça va
être celui qui sort le ce couple le plus
sensationnel et l'a donc au niveau en
danger bien dans du web depuis le début
de l'année en france les services de
police ont intercepté plusieurs
séquences violente enregistrés dans des
établissements scolaires il s'agissait
jusqu'ici d'agressions entre élèves
[Musique]